first our top story this hour a
temporary ceasefire proposed by the
russians was expected to go into effect
this morning in ukraine the plan would
have allowed civilians safe passage out
of two parts of the country but now the
effort appears to be on hold as russia
russia's shelling continues and it
follows another explosive night across
much of the country the united nations
estimates as many as 4 million people
could be displaced in the coming weeks
that's about 10 percent of the
population many are fleeing to
neighboring poland where they are being
welcomed with no required paperwork
christina raffini is at a border
crossing in poland christina good
morning
good morning we're at the kachova border
crossing between poland and ukraine
where it's snowing and freezing and all
morning we've seen lines of refugees
waiting out in the cold to board buses
to refugee receiving centers other
places in poland now we've seen a lot of
mothers we've seen children that's
because military-aged men are not
allowed to leave the country and more
families are having to make the
heartbreaking decision to separate
saying last goodbyes through train
station gates or windows now secretary
of state lincoln landed in poland this
morning he was in brussels yesterday
where he was asked if nato would
consider instituting a no-fly zone over
ukraine lincoln said the only way to
enforce that would be put u.s and nato
planes in a face-off situation with
russian fighters and he said president
biden has been clear we are not going to
get in a war with russia now what the
u.s has done is send thousands of troops
to reinforce nato allies like poland
yesterday we visited an airstrip on the
side of a rural road where the 82nd
airborne has heavy equipment and is
setting up a temporary base of
operations just one of the many around
here as the u.s tries to reassure nato
allies it has their backs now people
here in poland are nervous yesterday
poland's ambassador to ukraine said he
doesn't think kev will fall because
there are a lot of people on the street
he wouldn't want to meet if he were a
russian however he said if ukraine does
fall poland could be next michelle
christina thank you